midsummer is a horror movie about a
Swedish festival gone very very wrong
the film was written and directed by Ari
Astor the man behind 28 teens hereditary
this follow-up
is equally disturbing and just as
baffling here are all of the symbols and
hidden references in the movie and how
they relate to it's shocking ending
warning spoilers ahead first of all
while midsummer quickly turns into a
cultish nightmare the movie is
ultimately about the end of a
relationship between the two main
characters Danny and Christian Ari Astor
was recovering from a breakup of his own
while he was developing the film and
that experience influenced his writing
of the characters in particular Danny
he was also inspired by romantic films
like 1973's
scenes from a marriage and 1980 ones
modern romance I don't think we should
go as for his horror influences there's
a clear reference to the shining in this
overhead shot of the journey early in
the movie the paintings on the walls of
the apartments hint toward the ending of
the film and the very messy breakup we
witness in Christians apartment we see a
painting by Brooklyn based artists Moop
on the work is part of a series called
Dino [ __ ] a title that seems very
appropriate for Christians character
given his callous treatment of Danny
also visible is this work by swedish
artist john bauer it depicts a little
girl in a crown facing a large bear this
painting directly alludes to the movies
ending when Christian is placed inside a
bear carcass and set on fire
Danny watches him burn while wearing a
crown of flowers later in Sif's house
Christian also sees an image on the wall
of a bear being burned alive
further foreshadowing his untimely death
so
just gonna ignore the bed it's a bear
Astor compared the sacrificial burning
of the temple to the burning of a box of
a Nexus personal items as a sort of
catharsis post-breakup only of course
far more extreme the sacrificial burning
at the end also calls back the ending of
the wicker man in which the outsider
main character is placed in a wooden
statue and set afire Astor and his team
spent months researching Scandinavian
and Germanic folklore and scattered
Easter eggs throughout the film which
also hinted the culmination of Danny and
Christians relationship major plot
points and other characters deaths one
of the most important set pieces the
bunkhouse exemplifies this attention to
detail the inner walls are covered in
elaborate murals painted by artists
Bragg Nair person and based on medieval
art if you look closely these images
actually reveal much of the plot
basically the bunkhouse fulfills the
same function as the dollhouse did and
hereditary illustrating much of the
story before it actually happens for
example above one of the beds we see an
illustration of two people having sex
surrounded by onlookers this clearly
refers to the mating ritual Christians
later lured into to impregnate Maya this
scene is also hinted at when the boys
are eating earlier in the film and
discussing all of the Swedish girls they
plan on impregnating during the trip
another illustration shows people
cutting their hands as a sacrifice soon
after we see the old couple cut their
palms atop the cliff right before they
jump to their deaths also covering the
walls are many runes an ancient language
that features heavily throughout the
film at one point the characters refer
to the runes as elder futhark and
younger futhark to evolutions of the
same system of language looking at the
meanings of some of these symbols we can
try to piece together why Astor chose
them in certain parts of the movie he
assigned each character a rune which we
can see clearly on their robes Danny has
an are rune on her dress which
symbolizes a ride or journey this likely
refers to her own journey of
finally coming to terms with the truth
about her relationship
the hourglass-shaped room next to it
symbolizes day or an awakening this
likely refers to Danny's breakthrough
about Christian a moment of clarity for
her
Danny's character also experiences a
slow reawakening throughout the festival
the first sign of her rebirth is when
she wakes up from her nap
and suddenly her skin appears golden and
almost glittery meanwhile Christians
robe has an up arrow room which could
reference either the male symbol or a
willingness to self-sacrifice ironically
equality he does not have the first
bloody sacrifice we witness is that of
two senior members of the community who
throw themselves off a cliff this
tradition is called at a stupa it's
based off of Nordic legends in which
people would commit ritual suicide when
they grew too old to care for themselves
any longer when the man and woman rubbed
their bloody hands on the rune stones
the two symbols that appear are the are
from Danny's robe and the up-arrow from
Christians robe the shape of the
dining-table is also significant this
rune symbolises tradition the passing
down of rituals and rites if you look
closely at the Sun like entrance to the
village you'll see the same shape but
upside down the X inside the sacred
temple can mean gift which makes sense
as the community is planning on gifting
nine souls to the gods beyond the
bunkhouse murals there's a tapestry in
the open field that also foretells parts
of the plot it depicts a bizarre love
story in which a girl puts her menstrual
blood and pubic hair in a boy's food and
drink to make him fall in love with her
this is exactly what Maya does to
Christian you can see here that his
drink is darker than the others with a
reddish tint and he pulls a pubic hair
out of his mouth after taking a bite of
the pie while the most horrific events
in the film are fictitious the holiday
and many of its rituals are very real
midsummer is an annual event that takes
place in mid-june around the summer
solstice
it's popular across the globe
particularly in Scandinavia and it's
even depicted briefly in the Disney
movie frozen
mid-summer was initially a pagan holiday
but it eventually merged with the
Christian feast day of st. John the
Baptist a celebration of the prophets
birth indeed there are several
references to John the Baptist in the
film Pal tells Danny that the festival
lasts nine days and that the event is
special because it only occurs every 90
years in the Bible the Virgin Mary
stayed with John the Baptist mother
Elizabeth for 90 days before Elizabeth
gave birth then when they get to the
field outside the village Inga more
wishes pal a happy st. John's in Swedish
one of the flowers that covers the
village is st. John's wort it's
customary to celebrate st. John's day
with bonfires like the one that burned
the sacrifices alive in the final scene
and with torches like those that the
villagers carry throughout the film one
of the key components of midsummer is
the maple which we see in the film
covered in flowers and greenery for good
luck the ritual in which the villagers
dance around the Maypole is based in a
real-life midsummer custom one that
revolves around procreation and
fertility so it makes sense that
Christians bizarre sex ritual is a major
part of what comes next the community
makes way for new life by making a lot
of bloody sacrifices let's start with
what happened to Josh when he goes to
bed on his last night he's already set
on sneaking into the barn to photograph
the holy book the camera lingers on his
shoes as he pulls the blanket over his
body the shot of his sneakers may be
referencing the mass suicide of the
Heaven's Gate cult in 1997 when 39 cult
members were found dead on their bunk
beds having taken a powerful sedative
and covered themselves in purple sheets
as an anthropology student Josh is
obsessed with Northern European pagan
traditions to the extent where he's
fully embraced this cult in Sweden his
ambition and academic passion is
ultimately what brings his demise in the
barn
josh is attacked by oath the same man
who got angry at Marc for peeing on the
ancestral tree the most disturbing part
both is now wearing mark state
later we see the skin of marks face
placed on a straw dummy and topped off
with the jesters hat this cruel fate is
foreshadowed earlier in the movie what
they play it's giving the food in
retrospect this bit of foreshadowing
makes sense as Mark pretty neatly fit
the comedic archetype of the fool an
even greater horror is done to Simon The
Londoner who mysteriously disappeared
without his fiancee Connie
Christian stumbles on Simon tied face
down in the chicken coop with his back
sliced open and liver and ribs exposed
as we look closer we see that his lungs
are moving indicating that Simon is
still alive if you're wondering how
anyone could come up with this stuff it
turns out Astor did months of research
on Viking torture techniques what Simon
subjected to is right in line with the
blood eagle method of execution by
torture a prolonged type of ritual
killing detailed in Norse poetry so why
have such brutal Viking rituals survived
in this insular community and what does
it all mean
to get an idea we should look to Reuben
the so called Oracle in the community
as an elder in the village explains
Reuben was purposely inbred to serve as
a conduit for the word of the Gods the
boy is said to have unclouded judgment
as a result of his condition and his
pure blood towards the end of the movie
he's shown sitting on a seat covered in
cotton looking almost like he's sitting
on a cloud in asters words Reuben
embodies the political message of the
film which is perhaps partly critiquing
the global rise of xenophobia and the
return of the far-right in Sweden as
aster said in an interview if you
consider Swedish history it is a very
closed society and what does that really
mean there are things happening in
Sweden right now that are echoes of
things that happen in the Second World
War
okay now back to the ending of the film
it seems that the burning of the sacred
temple was part of Pels plan from the
very beginning one theory while Danny's
families seemed to die in a
murder-suicide what if it was actually
set up next to her parents bed was a
crown of flowers and there are similar
yellow flowers on their wallpaper to a
mysterious bit of foreshadowing what if
say Pal killed Danny's family to trigger
the series of events that led her to the
festival he does emphasize that he was
most looking forward to Danny coming
along on the trip more than anyone else
whether or not Danny was chosen by pal
there are some other hints that she was
always a perfect candidate for May Queen
one is her birthday which Powell is well
aware coincides with the beginning of
the festival
Danny's in her mid-20s which is
significant because as Pal explains his
community thinks of one's life in terms
of seasons the first 16 years of life
are equivalent to one season spring
Danny is midway through the next season
summer so literally midsummer regardless
of the impetus for Danny's journey the
movie comes full tragic circle by the
end beginning with the deaths of her
family and ending with the death of
Christian as Astor says you start with
the unfathomable and you end with the
unfathomable so did we miss anything let
us know in the comments
you